hello there my good man i'll have a
double shot of broken pearl necklace and
a ruined zorro showing
um i don't think we serve those drinks
here
drinks after the legendary arkham series
by rocksteady ended it seemed as though
warner brothers wanted to keep batman
fresh in the mind of gamers
so they licensed the character to
telltale games better known as the
developer that made
everyone ever cry in 2012 and then
realized that they peaked early as the
quality of the games gradually declined
until they financially imploded
but they got a few good attempts in
there at bringing their vision of the
dark knight to life and today i want to
take you back through the first season
to see how they did
because i think with a few clever
reinventions and new ideas
this turned out to be a pretty fresh
take on batman this review was requested
on my patreon by gwynblade
i appreciate his help and i want to give
a shout out since he just became a
father so welcome to baby elena she'll
be a badass crime fighting sidekick in
no time
if you want to request a review and get
a personalized shout out head over to my
patreon and of course donating to the
lower tiers definitely helps me out too
that's a fine batmobile it's nice to
have a modern batman adaptation where
he's not driving
a tank through buildings for a change
but hey you can blame him it's not like
he can't afford to pay for the damage in
fact bruce wayne is probably pulling
that fancy wallet out to pay for one
destructed building or another every
night
if you want a wallet that can carry your
valuables and fitness slim utility belt
then check out today's sponsor
this video is sponsored by exter the
world's largest smart wallet brand whose
goal is to design
innovative solutions to the way you
carry items extra was kind enough to
ship me one of their awesome smart
wallets so i could unbox it and check it
out for you
right off the bat i'm struck by how thin
it is compared to other wallets
it's like the same size as a typical
cell phone but it still carries just as
much for your cards and cash
it has a handy button on it extending
all your cards without opening it which
feels useful enough to accompany any
crime fighter's set of tools
and of course it comes in black what
makes it even more revolutionary is this
tracking card that comes with it
no competent vigilante detective would
risk losing his cash on a night of
battling villainy
so it comes equipped with a handy solar
powered tracking card that hooks up to
this app on your phone
so this is one wallet you don't have to
worry about losing whether your identity
is a secret or not
identity theft is no laughing matter but
extra's smart wallets are designed to
protect you from skimming and potential
thieves with their easy to use solutions
for always keeping track of your money
be a smart dark knight detective
and try out one of extra's smart wallets
and various other time-saving designs to
carry better using the link in the
description
now back to the video regarding telltale
games i've always had mixed feelings
about them when they were in their prime
on the one hand it's interesting to have
a series of games that are so different
from your typical
aaa blockbuster games there have been
times where i actually got very tired of
shooters and massacring infinite waves
of vaguely european vaguely middle
eastern terrorists
or space aliens or zombies sometimes it
feels like all video games are just
shooting and sometimes that's radish
[ __ ]
but sometimes i can get burnt out on it
when it's like the 2000th consecutive
shotgun head explosion i'm a man who
likes variety
it's a neat alternative to have a game
where shotgun head explosions aren't the
main objective and i can sit back and
enjoy
a nice story it's also a plus that
telltale offered graphic adventure
narrative based games with licensed
characters from big franchises
it's nice to see that a game about
batman can take a form other than the
glossy
complex gameplay of the arkham series
bruce wayne in his daily life
are such an absolute non-entity in those
games because of the heavy action focus
that it feels like you're missing out on
a substantial part of that character
his duality but on the other hand
telltale games all have a handful of the
same
problems that interrupt their novelty
these games are holding together with
duct tape and paper clips because
telltale refused to use a new engine to
make these
these games are buggier than batman's
rogues gallery
holy texture pop-ins batman how am i
supposed to defeat crime if i teleport
in and out of the scene every time the
camera switches to a new angle
oh god it hurts my molecules are being
ripped apart and reforming every time
the episode recap changes slug lines
interior wayne manor knight
and aside from the technical issues that
really take you out of the story there's
the biggest problem with games that
emphasize
choice there is no choice spoilers for a
9 year old game incoming
it doesn't matter how well you played
the game lee still gets bit by the
walker and dies because the game decided
it
doesn't matter if you cut your arm off
to stop the zombie infection
lee still isn't in the sequels because
it would be too hard to write or
program a route that drastically
different for the narrative of these
future games
so sometimes you feel a little cheated
that everything plays out the same no
matter
what you do it doesn't matter which
emotionally abusive parental figure you
kill in this scene
via the power of time skips they won't
be showing up later for more than one
scene so who cares
may as well kill them both this isn't a
problem specific to telltale
but just this entire genre of games
there isn't even an illusion of choice
sometimes
you just really feel like nothing you do
or say will affect the overall outcome
but on the other hand i also get very
tired of how these games have a pretty
binary good and bad choice i have this
weird experience playing these games
where i get mild anxiety when presented
with a choice because i feel like i'm
going to be punished for them constantly
by having scenes taken away
characters killed off early or having to
be forced to sit through additional
scenes where characters admonish you for
clicking the renegade option
you and me we're on shaky ground gym
no listen to me the excessive violence
it can't go on i understand the idea is
to have your choices have consequences
but that feels cheapened when there's a
situation where it's really just a flat
out incorrect course of action
this one has consequences this one
doesn't i want these games to be written
and designed under the mantra of
there are no right or wrong answers just
different ones
how about instead of choice a makes
everyone hate you and choice b
makes everyone love you make it a little
more neutral for both so you don't just
look at your options and go
damn why on earth would anyone ever
choose that i'm not an [ __ ]
give me more morally grey decisions
where some people are down with it and
some aren't
and obviously this problem doesn't
persist entirely through these games
it's just every once in a while but
often enough that it bothers me
i personally feel like the best telltale
game was the wolf among us
because that one did such a good job of
not punishing you for everything you did
you just solved situations however you
saw fit and had to live with it and
ponder it yourself
sometimes other characters would or
wouldn't approve but you weren't
punished repeatedly for it
not that i remember anyway it's been a
while since i played it as far as i can
tell that game had the least amount of
choices where it would just call you a
big piece of [ __ ] every 20 seconds if
you chose the wrong flavor of birthday
cake
big b you like vanilla [ __ ] yourself you
monster introducing suave utility belt
hair and conditioner
for men for the discerning gentleman you
want hair that has volume and texture
that really
says when you walk into a room i am the
only ethical billionaire
so how does telltale's batman fare
considering these issues
it has some of the typical jank you'd
expect from these games but it runs
smoother than all the other ones i've
played thankfully
that's not to say it's completely
glitchless there's
still sometimes scenes where character
models are just completely invisible so
it looks like batman's talking the
voices in his head
it's over drop the gun look i promise
i'm not gonna shoot you okay
you step into the shoes of crackhead
billionaire bruce wayne portrayed by
sterling archer
and follow his daily journeys dealing
with the political landscape of gotham
city and managing his own reputation
as well as his nightly escapades as a
brooding animal-themed ninja detective
that has a fetish for cat girls
that was impre i did that all in one
breath that was impressive right
our story goes that bruce is a young and
early batman that's still figuring
things out
and mostly just fighting normal human
criminals he hasn't graduated to the
crocodile men or shape-shifting mud
monsters yet
while trying to tear down gotham's
biggest crime boss by day and night
it's alleged by the media that bruce
wayne's parents were the boss's
accomplices back in the day
before their untimely slow motion death
and by proxy bruce is now
implicated in several crimes on top of
having to fight to clear his good name
by day
by night batman has to get to the bottom
of the mystery who's running the
powerful crime syndicate known as the
children of arkham
who have taken a cause and complete
anarchy to expose gotham's corrupt elite
the children of mario the music box
arkham are killing politicians
crime lords police officers and pretty
much everyone who gets in their way
to create a revolution on the streets of
gotham and you as the batman have to
prove that killing and torturing people
isn't the solution
unless you pick all the options to kill
and torture people
but that's silly and yeah you get to
have a qte sex scene with catwoman so
it's a pretty good game
and even though most telltale choose
your own adventure dvds feel pretty
similar this one's got its own
signatures to help it stand out from the
rest
i really enjoy what tattletail games
does with batman his combat and action
scenes are well choreographed quick time
events rather than the usual free flow
combat
i like how the fight scene still flows
pretty well even if you fail prompt
because it gives a sense that batman
just took the hit and decided to
anticipate the next move
making him feel more human and
vulnerable but still extremely skilled
as a fighter it's also neat that you
have these sections where you can stop
and plan your method of attack when you
go into an area
like which guys to take out in which
order what weapons or environmental
objects you will use to hit them
it gives you a nice amount of variety
and player input over the combat that
isn't really in most of the other
travelers tales games
the slow puzzle solving investigation
segments feel right at home on a batman
story
and offer a nice lower tech alternative
to the highly streamlined and automated
detective scenes in the arkham series
i think those levels were fun but often
times it started to give the wrong
impression that batman was relying too
heavily on the computers and holograms
to do all the brain work
here batman is literally connecting the
dots at the crime scene and figuring out
how every piece of evidence on the
ground relates to every other one
you still have crazy future space
holograms flying around in your cowl to
visualize the solutions
but you get more of a sense that it's
bruce himself putting it all together in
the puzzle
and what kind of ceo goes into a board
meeting with dry skin
our new moisturizing face and body wash
heist
cat lets the ladies know you can scratch
kitty back
batman is definitely the most high
profile character to be used in the
telltale format
and you may be wondering how they
handled him and his world i honestly
really like this take on the batman
mythos
it feels different and new but it has
the right tone and presentation
it still feels like batman even if the
details are different
batman himself is portrayed as very
humble and human and i like how he
doesn't always have all the answers
i've said it a million times but i
prefer a batman to be in touch with his
human side and to be at least
a little friendly to the right people
don't get me wrong i can still enjoy a
character that's a complete psychopath
with no connection to humanity
whatsoever
i love the punisher but i don't like the
punisher being written more like batman
or batman being written more like the
punisher
you dig but because it's a choice based
game you have the option to create this
horrific paradox where in the automatic
dialogue bruce is very neutral and calm
but then you choose all the most cruel
vile [ __ ] to say and do and act like a
cold heartless slightly fascist frank
miller batman
what are you dense and as funny as this
type of dialogue option is in a
compilation on youtube
i never choose them when talking to
someone like alfred or catwoman
i play these games like commander
shepard nice to the crew a dick to you
in fact i wouldn't trust anyone if i saw
them act mean to alfred in this game
that's the mark of a real sicko murderer
man if you see someone's alfred has an
eye patch in season two
then be suspicious because they're
probably a serial killer obviously the
game takes pretty big liberties with
penguin and two-face
but in a way that the basics are all
there for both of them penguin's a
ruthless criminal that's angry at the
world because his rich and successful
family fell onto ruin when he was young
they still got that two-face or harvey
dent is the kind-hearted district
attorney whose did pushes him to a life
of crime
yeah yeah pretty much one of the aspects
of this game's story i find most
interesting is how you can build or tear
down relationships with all these
established batman characters
this is where the telltale format shines
the best when they get it right
they get it really right you can
cultivate your romantic feelings with
catwoman throughout the story
until she has a hard choice between
leaving the city or staying to be your
tom king waifu or you can just
completely stonewall her advances at
every turn until she's so down bad she
doesn't care what the [ __ ] happens to
you
you can maintain your friendship with
harvey dent who is an
honest and kind guy that's a little
thoughtless at times
he struggles with mental illness that
leads him down a dark path
devolving into becoming aaron eckhart's
exposed jaw tendons you have the choice
to be caring and supportive of him
and choosing his well-being over others
or you can let your friendship with him
wither
accelerating his transition to two-face
you even get the option to stop him from
being all
burned up and deformed so his mental
breakdown is purely internal instead of
a physical transformation
but where's the fun in that he should
look like a scary bad guy
i appreciate the choice though
unfortunately the cold reality of these
games being very limited in their
branching path sets back in when you
realize that no matter what you do
harvey still becomes two-faced in one
way or another you have the ability to
change how quickly his personality
regresses and whether he hates batman or
bruce wayne more
but you can't change his fate no matter
what you do
that should have been telltale's slogan
when you're going out for a night on the
town you want to make sure your jawline
sends a good impression
with rubber cowl the best aftershave on
the market
what's there with these characters and
story lines is pretty good but i wish
there was a way to have more of an
effect on it in season one
telltale does however make good use of
the character in a way that i think
most modern adaptations of batman could
take at least some cues from
acknowledging the big old elephant in
the room of all batman discourse lately
that being
you can't do this
no please god no
wait batman is
i have to tweet this
the old batman bad because money
discourse
i admire this game's bravery in tackling
the subject
every two weeks on twitter some brain
dead clout chasing android incapable of
original ideas or critical thought posts
another
hot take about batman being an evil
billionaire who beats up homeless people
and people of color and the mentally ill
these tweets are always worded so
similarly that i have to believe they're
being generated by a bot
or some kind of space parasite that has
all of these people enslaved to a
telepathic hive mind
of ill-informed takes or performative
intellectualism
they always post this with a sense of
self-satisfaction as if they're the
first person to ever make such a bold
claim
not realizing they're a dime a dozen and
every one of them has to be as reductive
as possible to make this point
even when it's not a point at all
sometimes it's a played out joke
but most often they think it's clever in
original criticism
that the source material itself doesn't
address
constantly carmine falcone the rich
white crime boss who lives in a
penthouse and has made millions off the
drug trade to poor communities
who influences politics by forcefully
strong arming politicians into letting
him get away with illicit activity
the guy who's bribing cops and sending
them to beat people up on his behalf
yeah that guy's just a mentally ill
homeless man how dare batman hurt such
an
upstanding and underprivileged citizen
the joker a
white domestic terrorist who has killed
scores of people indiscriminately
bombs buildings tortures women beats
kids to death
kidnaps hundreds of babies creates
chemical weapons
you name it pretty much any bad thing
he's probably done
well if bruce wayne had spent more of
his money improving mental health care
instead of being batman
this never would have happened or wait
don't worry though i am not doing this
alone with bruce's help
we're replacing the dangerously unsecure
arkham asylum
with a state-of-the-art mental health
facility to help gotham's most
at-risk individuals and yet twitter
activist of the week still gets 300 000
retweets for saying bruce wayne is the
bad guy
like i get it billionaires are shitty
people who use their money
horribly and will take any opportunity
to [ __ ] on the little guy on the street
but the premise of batman is what if one
of them was a good guy and on our side
and these people will still go so far
out of their way to miss the point of
that
just so they can get that hit of
serotonin from all the likes and
retweets from
other people who don't have the first
clue what they're talking about
the whole thing is ridiculous and yeah
sure a good guy billionaire is pretty
unrealistic
but so is the idea of batman not
shattering his knees from all the
superhero landings or tearing his acl by
throwing a kick wrong at bane
bruce wayne isn't idealized either he's
still a person with some pretty major
character flaws and hang ups
but god damn it he's trying his best
and yet more contemporary batman
adaptations try to offset his kindness
even further by surrounding batman with
negative examples of people using their
money for evil
it doesn't take much imagination to
envision these robots on the battlefield
except i won't allow it what
i don't like guns this time including
his own parents
telltale's game had some major cajones
to pull a twist like this one
and stick with it but it holds a mirror
up to the idea of bruce wayne's parents
being these two
perfect idealized people who were killed
for no reason
most batman stories tend to look at the
wanes with rose-colored glasses and
portray them as
perfect generous people who didn't
deserve what happened to them
in the depression your father nearly
bankrupted wayne enterprises combating
poverty
he believed that his example could
inspire the wealthy of gotham to save
their city
that adds to the tragedy of their demise
and it makes sense to have bruce want to
follow in their example
in a sort of uncle ben kind of way i say
there's room for a different version of
the story here and there too
i don't mind a different take because
it's handled well and told in an
interesting way
in the telltale universe negan and
maggie wayne are actually criminals with
ties to the mob
and their deaths were no random accident
it wasn't unlucky
they were assassinated it's interesting
to have a unique take on batman where
his family name
isn't so squeaky clean and he has to
rise above what his parents did and be
better than them he's rejecting the old
ways of the wanes and fighting to
preserve his memory of them
even if that doesn't match how they
really were in reality
alfred was afraid of bruce's parents and
tried to protect him as a kid from the
darker parts of their history
because he knew it would break his heart
to find out they weren't the heroes he
imagined them to be
i created all of this because i didn't
want any more innocent people
to die if falcone is telling the truth
about my parents
then what the hell did we do this for
but instead of letting that break him of
his desire to be batman it strengthens
it
he knows his parents did a lot of damage
to gotham and stood on a lot of people
to get that amount of money
he takes it as a sign that he has to
continue harder than before
in trying to give back he redeems his
family name by being better than them
it's a pretty drastic change from the
usual origin but like i said
there's room in the world for one
retelling i don't want that to become
the default batman story from now on
but i like to see something that's so
unabashedly in elseworld
it's one of those changes that the story
itself can justify
by doing interesting things with the
idea instead of just change for the sake
of change
and the villain of season 1 is exemplary
of all of that a very drastic change
from what we know
but utilized in a neat way without going
too much into the spoiler territory
because i do recommend you play this
game
the villain doesn't necessarily 100 work
for me but i appreciate the attempt and
maybe you'll find it interesting too
telltale batman isn't perfect by any
means it's got the same usual
performance
issues as a game and some of the
hallmarks of what made telltale
frustrating at times but underneath
it's got a really cool alternate take on
batman's world and characters
and while i haven't played it yet i've
heard that season 2 doubles down on that
aspect and kept trying new things
maybe they don't work for everyone but
it's cool to see something different
being attempted if you're a batman fan
that's open-minded then maybe this game
will do something for you
[Music]
[Music]
you